I mean I don't know what's going to
happen this is not going to be a race
between Joe Biden and Donald Trump I
would bet my beloved fishing camp in
Maine that that is not going to happen
that's not going to happen so what will
happen well I don't know one of like 400
distinct other possibilities I mean I
just can't even you know pick one by the
way it's Gavin Newsome we all should be
very very concerned that guy's scary and
I mean it I mean it scary this is this
will be forced these issues will be
forced soon like in a
year and the road from here to November
of 2024 is going to be filled with
developments nobody in this room could
foree I can promise you that so
everything's a sick what wouldn't they
do what haven't they done what might
they do next let your imagination run
wild so the question the only one that
you can answer is how will
you prepare yourself for that the white
pill is the last line that he said you
can care you can fight you can wake up
you can take a little more power also
within your personal life